good morning hello guys my name is Asher
now it's about 7:30 a.m. just working up
today's gonna be the first day of hazel
2d so I'm gonna be working on the 2d
rendering side of hazel I thought that I
would record kind of my day I guess is
like a bit of a vlog just to show you
guys how the day goes and how hazel
Trudi goes so this is gonna be kind of
like a day in the life let me know what
you guys think of this kind of video
hopefully you'll enjoy it never really
done anything like this before so right
now my wife Anya is home this morning so
we're gonna go and make some coffee and
some breakfast and then after that I
think she's she's gotta go off to work
and do like some fire training or
something and I'm gonna get right into
hazel Tunis
so that's pretty much how the day's
gonna go I don't know what else is gonna
happen should be pretty good but right
now go make some coffee and I just
talking about coffees making meat just
waking me up so just go ahead and make
some coffee
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay sorry now that I've had breakfast
we can finally get into some work so
I've already planned a pretty good deal
of tree on the whiteboard here there's
behind you guys specifically I just
wanted to go over what it is that I
wanted to achieve with 2d it's always
good to set goals and kind of I guess
define a certain level of features a
certain feature set that we want to kind
of include into your day I think it's
really good to have some kind of goal in
mind especially when you're working on
something like this because I think that
it kind of gets you excited and it's
nice to just kind of aim high and then
hopefully get to as high as you are
aiming to get to but don't get me wrong
I definitely don't to spend too much
time planning this I think that it's
very easy to fall into the trap of just
planning planning planning without
actually getting anything done 2d is
something that I have done before so
there's no reason for me not to kind of
try and jam it in but the thing is this
is 2d for hazel right and hazel is kind
of like the hazel engines kind of like
my baby it's like the big kind of
software project that I'm working on
it's my main kind of software project I
don't want to just jam in any kind of 2d
solution I want this to actually be good
so I definitely don't want to just kind
of blindly start typing code and then
you know make some bad decisions down
the road so I still have taken a bit of
time to think about it I think that with
software in general though it's
obviously way better to just iterate
over it rather than just sit down and
plan this amazing thing and then pull it
off and then everything's perfect
because it usually doesn't work out that
way it's usually a lot better to
actually start with something right plan
a little bit start typing the code start
making stuff work and then halfway
through realize okay we've got something
up and running but it's a bit too slow
right it's just I'm able to like display
like I don't know a hundred thousand
sprites that's not good enough I want
more right and then on that kind of noir
you kind of go back to retrace your
steps you come up with a better solution
you figure out why it's slow in the
first place you get a read over it
because a lot of the time I found is
that you know you want to go for this
incredible solution but you don't really
need it it's kind of like those people
who say that premature optimize a
is the root of all evil which is
something that I I don't really think
that that it's like the root of all evil
don't think isn't that bad I think that
optimization is good at any level but to
an extent I guess they're right in the
sense that you sometimes end up over
engineering solutions you sometimes end
up creating stuff that you don't
actually need right and that can be a
problem in itself because apart from
making something that's just way too
fast for example I know it sounds crazy
like how can something be way too fast
sure but if you've spent all that
engineering time on this right is it
even that important is it even worth all
of your time those are really good
questions
I really hate people who just are all
talk who just talk the talk but they
don't walk the walk right all talk no
walk I don't like that stop talking
about what you're gonna do and actually
start doing it that's pretty much how
I'm gonna handle hazel today I'm not
gonna spend too much time talking about
how great it's gonna be and how I'm
gonna do all this I'm just gonna set a
very concise goal right 1 million
particles I want 1 million 2d sprites on
the screen at one time that's gonna be
my goal just throwing that number out
there a million seems like a lot I know
it's possible let's go for a million
particles it's gonna be our goal and I'm
just gonna get to work and make it
happen so the first thing I want to do
is start with the public hazel
repository I gave this a bit of thought
and I decided that I don't want to start
with hazel dev because that is pretty
much a 3d renderer there's no 2d there
at all
and so for me to kind of start ripping
out you know the 3d renderer I'm like
abstracting it properly so that we can
have both 2d and 3d that's going to be a
little waste of time I'm literally gonna
go over to github.com slash the Cherno
slash hazel clone out repository and
start from there as it is today in fact
please take a look at it I mean
well it doesn't mean have a readme file
like it's just got hazel you know I
think today is gonna be a pretty good
maintenance opportunity we'll say as
well because what I'm gonna do here is I
want to make a proper readme I think for
hazel so that people can actually people
have been leaving comments for so long
being like I can't clone hazel it
doesn't compile for me for some reason
and it's usually because they're not
recursively cloning all of the sub
methods as well I think a readme file
would really benefit from that so we're
gonna go ahead and apart from getting
Tweety just like I want some sprites on
the screen - by the end of today that's
how we're doing this we're actually
gonna get stuff done today
apart from that I'm also gonna fix up
this repository I think so anyway enough
talking
hazel today let's do this
[Music]
okay so it's been a couple hours and I
really got into the idea of making a
good read me page for hazel some kind of
like cover page that just tells everyone
how to actually download the engine and
use it because I know that for like
literally as long as it's existed people
have had issues with that so that I
thought I'd be super productive and get
that done but you know what are you
gonna put here right like you need to
have some kind of logo so I decided to
spend a while coming up with some kind
of logo for hazel and this is kind of
what I came up with it's really plain
it's really simple here is on white and
here it is on black in terms of like my
inspiration for this really I just
wanted something really really clean I
looked at the other kind of engine logos
out there like unreal unity and
frostbite probably my favorite one out
of those was definitely unreal and you
can see that basically what they've got
is just like the letter U in kind of a
stylized way here that almost depicts
some kind of role-playing game or
something like that when you look at it
they had a circle around it which I also
actually tried but I that looked that
just looks like a helipad and also I
just doesn't like it at all
so um I kind of got rid of the circle I
didn't want to go with that and just
ended up with something really clean
like this so let me know what you guys
think of this logo if the hazel since
we're in a sense we're entering 2d it's
also a good kind of candidate for a
texture just to put into the engine to
have and yeah I mean I really like it
and it's a couple hours of work but I
think so far that this might be the
official hazel logo magic coming soon so
right about now it's looking like
lunchtime and with anya coming home soon
from a little work thing i thought that
i try and make something nice for us
lately i've been really getting into
making japanese food really since our
honeymoon in japan we've been just even
more into japanese food than we were
before a few days ago i made a really
nice curry katsu and today i thought
that i'd give the the kind of onion and
egg sauce just really a regular cat suit
on a shot i find it it's really nice to
take a break from kind of just
programming and sitting at your desk and
just to go out and just try and make
something
in the kitchen cooking with Cherno
really is a real thing definitely some
things I'm going to change for next time
I make this but otherwise I think it
turned out pretty okay for a first
attempt and of course after this
delicious lunch it's time to get back to
work on Essen today I kind of like about
working in the afternoons mornings our
mornings and evenings for me are a lot
more productive I think usually in the
afternoon I like to go to the gym or
just go outside and do something like
that because I find that if I sit at my
desk I'll just kind of stuff
procrastinating watching YouTube videos
not really spending time working but
today I thought that I'd stick it out
because I needed something to show you
guys of course
so thanks I just want to take a moment
to thank our sponsors for this video PBS
studio for those of you who don't know
PBS studio is something called a static
analyzer and if you're not using one of
these well you really should what a
static analyzer does is it looks through
the source code that you've written and
it just looks for mistakes or things
that you've written that it doesn't
think that you meant to write so it's
quite common for example when you copy
and paste code that you accidentally
forget to change the names of certain
variables and then later down the road
of course everything will compile
everything will run but you'll run into
issues that might not be 100% apparent
and I'm using PBS studio right now just
as an extension for visual studio and as
I'm writing all of this hazel 2d code is
just continually checking it for any
mistakes that I may have written it's
almost like a spell checker for say bus
Plus and it also works with C Java
c-sharp really with anything that you're
probably building PBS studio will just
check it for you it's kind of like an
automated code review instead of getting
someone to go ahead and review your work
you can just let PBS studio do it and in
fact it also points out things that you
could optimize to make your code run
faster and tells you how to actually do
that so previous studio reached out to
me around two weeks ago and ever since
then I've been using that product pretty
much every day for every project that
I've been working on and right now even
for hazel 2d like it's pointed out some
pretty good stuff so eventually a
real-world issue from today I had this
weird problem where if I launched hazel
the camera basically wouldn't render
anything at all like we you wouldn't see
anything until you resized the window
and that was odd because I was pretty
sure that my logic
for resizing the window was identical to
what it was during construction I mean
you can see here that I'm just making a
new orthographic camera I've got my
aspect ratio for my camera zoom the
exact same code is being called here
right so I've got my camera got my
aspect ratio got my camera zoom it's
being constructed if we look at them
they're both initialized we have our
camera zoom we have our aspect ratio
what is the problem why is it not
rendering anything until I resize so I
ran PBS studio through all of this and I
noticed that whilst there were a lot of
things here there were two actual errors
that popped up here the initialized
class member a mass spec racer is used
to initialize M cam remember remember
the members are initialized in the order
of their declarations instead of class I
love that it actually explains what it
is because I looked at this and I was
like what do you mean the uninitialized
class member aspect ratio is used to
initialize camera I mean sure it's not
initialized here but aspect ratio
definitely is initialized and it was
only after I actually read that members
are initialized in the order of their
declarations that I remembered well of
course this isn't working because camera
is being initialized up here but then
the camera zoom in aspect ratio is being
initialized here which means that since
everything gets initialized in the order
that it is declared this camera
initializer which is located in the
constructor is using aspect ratio and
camera zoom as they appear during this
line of code basically which means that
they're not initialized at all and
therefore I was just doing uninitialized
memory as it's accessing on initialize
memory and nothing was working so by
simply moving the camera zoom and the
camera aspect ratio up before I actually
initialized the camera if we take a look
at what that looks like of course it
will be completely fixed when no longer
accessing uninitialized memory and as
you can see everything is working as it
should be immediately there are also a
bunch of really cool articles on the PBS
studio website that just kind of explain
all different things that PBS trio can
detect and just real world examples I'll
link one below in case you guys want to
take a look I found it pretty
interesting so PBS studio have been nice
enough to give you guys a 30-day free
trial instead of the usual 7 all you
have to do is go to the link in the
description of this video and just enter
the
promo code check go ahead and do that
now there's no reason not to try it out
run it through your projects I'm super
interested to see all the cool stuff
that it will pick up because as I
mentioned I've just been using it for
about two weeks I'm still quite new to
it and I'm definitely interested to see
what it can do for your source code and
of course huge thanks to PBS studio for
sponsoring these videos or some
companies like those that make it
possible for me to be doing this
full-time so anyway let's get back to
hazel today okay so now we are at the
end of the day it's not the evening of
what was a pretty long and quite
productive day actually I think that
making this day in the life kind of
thing actually forced me to do work
because of course I couldn't just go and
lay on the couch and just watch videos
and do nothing at all because I had to
you know film time lapses of me actually
working that also kept me on task so
it's actually quite interesting that
documenting your progress through
through like I guess a video through
video form really does actually benefit
you which is why I tell people who want
to make youtube videos but get no views
to just still do it because it's
actually quite useful for you as well
not to mention you of course improve
your skills anyway back to this so
basically what I did is exactly kind of
what I set out to do which was just to
try and render a whole bunch of sprites
at once what I did was I created this
sandbox 2d layer which is kind of the
same thing as a as the regular kind of
sandbox layer that you see in the game
engine series right now as of like when
this video got went up but um basically
what I did was refactored it a little
bit changed to rewrote the whole thing
really to be a specific 2d sandbox so to
test my 2d rendering which was kind of
the point of it if you look at the other
stuff that is in sandbox that's kind of
how it's supposed to work we have
sandbox app and what that does that
actually has this example layer which is
what we have in the game engine series
but instead of that what we have here is
a sandbox 2d layer that I'm pushing so
instead of this example I'm not pushing
that at all because if I did that would
of course render and also update and I
don't want those two layers interfering
because I haven't really set them up to
play nice with each other so I just have
my sandbox 2d layer and then from that
sandbox 2d layer
that has is just a whole bunch of
different like shaders I've stripped
most of the stuff out probably haven't
cleaned it up exactly but you can see
I've added some events for like Mouse
girl window resize stuff like that to
get that stuff to work and I also added
a whole bunch of debugging really so
that I could actually test this 2d
rendering stuff so I've got like stats
for rendering and all of this kind of
fun stuff like that and I'm actually
just I think creating the 2d renderer
right here in the sandbox layer for now
but basically what I've got is a pretty
simple clean API that I've written
I created this whole render a 2d thing
by the way I don't want to take you guys
through the code too much because
eventually that'll make it into videos
not to mention this will probably change
if you're really really interested in
the technical aspects behind this I can
maybe make a video I'll definitely make
one for patrons if they want as well but
I'm just not really the intention of
this video I think to show all the
technical details is more to just give
you guys an overview of what I've done
so we do have a whole bunch of code that
I've written here for the - for the 2d
renderer because it's a bad friend or
essentially so what you do is you you
basically give commands like draw quad
and then what that will do and you can
see that coming in through sandbox 2d
what that will do over here is basically
grab all the data that you're submitting
which is stuff like the position of the
of the quad that you're drawing the size
of the quad that you're drawing and then
the color of the quad that you're
drawing I'm just kind of using a
function here to define the color just
sort of that we get basically a gradient
across where that quad is positioned
essentially and then I'm drawing two
other quads basically this is all it
really takes to draw quad and then what
that actually does is it it pushes
vertices into a vertex buffer
dynamically and then we we upload that
vertex buffer to the GPU every frame
it's very very simple it's a it's
basically isn't a simple batter Andra
where instead of of course rendering
everything one by one and then having a
billion draw calls what you end up with
is just reducing the kind of draw calls
and then by bashing things together
which results in a much much faster
performance when you're rendering a lot
of geometry like this so I did a whole
bunch of arm gooey stuff as well so that
I could actually see the performance of
this
in real-time and then I just yeah I as I
mentioned just a whole bunch of stuff so
let's just take a look at what we
actually end up with so this is what
hazel looks like right now with the
sandbox 2d or the um and the sandbox 2d
layer pushed onto the layer stack so
this is what we have this is the
application I'll kind of make it a
little bit bigger so you guys can see
I'm just taking you through this a
little bit basically we have this kind
of world I guess it's being generated
it's a whole bunch of sprites and you
can see they're being submitted just
through these four loops that we have
here and this is all kind of dynamically
resizable and there are some statistics
here as well so we have to draw pools at
the moment not sure why we have to okay
well yeah the max quads per drawer is
10,000 so that's how many quads we can
batch together how many little
rectangles we can batch together into a
single draw we have 10,000 and two and
that would be why if we changed this to
10,000 and two that's 1,000 10,000 and
two you can see that we have one draw
call now of course because everything's
being patched together into a single
draw and a number of sprites is how many
sprites we have so you can basically
make this a larger or smaller to see
what the impact is like for performance
and you can see that that will of course
reflect over here which is the number of
quads that we're actually drawing now
137 you might be like number of surprise
137 why is that the case it's basically
one it's one axis 137 so what happens is
you of course end up with 137 times 137
or 137 squared because but the full loop
but the Y and the X and inside the
nested for loop will actually be
affected by the numbers price that's how
many sprites you get in one axis so the
x axis will have 137 y axis also 137 and
you get this whole grid of 137 squared
sprite plus true for these two that I
just decided to draw for some reason
anyway that's what we end up with and my
primary investigation here was of course
to see if I could even render a million
sprites using this strategy because this
is quite simple and I wasn't really sure
if it will be enough because like
generating vertices generating geometry
on the fly using something
my shadow I imagine would perform better
and it's probably something that I'll do
but I just wanted to see what I could
get with this as it was and I do have a
1080 TI GPU and a very good looking AMD
thread ripple in nineteen fifty X I
think the sixteen core thread Ripper
from like a year or two ago so very
beefy machine but I'm able to get pretty
good performance so it's hovering around
a millisecond here but if I bump the
number of sprites quite high you can see
that we're at about five milliseconds
now which I don't have a frame right
here but that's obviously quite a lot of
frames per second 16 milliseconds is
sixty frames per second and 33
milliseconds is thirty so if I bump this
basically all the way let's just see
what we get so at about I'm able to draw
about half a million and this keep in
mind this is with ten thousand and two
max quads per draw so it's splitting
this up into fifty one draw calls so
about 60 FPS we can get with half a
million quads so that's not bad and you
can see zooming out doesn't affect it
too much we're still at around 17
milliseconds here so that's not too bad
at all there are some spikes as you can
see but apart from that it's looking not
too bad at all and it's quite
interesting to look at I'm and then if
we bring this up so that we cross a
million or we'd reach a million you can
see that's at about 34 milliseconds so
around 30 frames per second which of
course is not good enough to be like 60
and it's not good enough to probably
render that many and you can see some
really interesting things start
happening when you zoom in at certain
levels because of the way that it's
trying to well I guess the pixels are
kind of fighting each other because
there's not enough fidelity of course
there's not enough resolution to display
all these gridlines which is interesting
but they go right and then of course if
we just lower instead of instead of
doing like a million if we just go back
to like 200 or something which is 40,000
and now I have to find my world again
the other thing that I wanted to play
with is to kind of just find out I guess
how many codes you could have in a draw
so what kind of the efficient well not
really efficient but well like an
optimal amount to have would be so
in other words at which point is it
better to have more drop calls rather
than having a huge batch of sprites
together and it's interesting to kind of
play around with that because you can
see if I reduce the max words per draw
nom and we kind of end up with letter
more draws as I do that it's interesting
to kind of just watch the performance
and see how it goes so you can see for
milliseconds we get with 50 calls per
draw because that's 785 trials that's a
lot whereas if I drag this up you can
see that the performance is a lot faster
doesn't really change too much but if I
drag it really down to like zero you can
see that performance is it takes 145
milliseconds which actually isn't too
bad for 40,000 roll calls I think but
probably because of my hardware but
that's obviously terrible and and then
as we kind of ease that up even doing
something alike 1200 draws is relatively
okay we get about five milliseconds but
that of course means that as I raise
this up using that kind of a batch of
that size I hit 16 milliseconds pretty
quickly or as if I just make this a
little bit bigger it goes down to 5
milliseconds so interesting to play
around with this it doesn't really look
like anything it doesn't really look
like anything above 10,000 certainly
would give you any performance increase
so like I don't know if we're struggling
here because we're hitting you know 24
milliseconds increasing that doesn't
necessarily seem - you can see the
drawers are going down but it was still
at about 26 milliseconds because we must
be hitting a brick wall somewhere else
probably just with the the amount of
data that we have to actually process in
the vertex shader and actually render
and the pixel shader so that's basically
well no I mean to rephrase that I
definitely don't think it's like fill
rate or anything like that that's
bottlenecking it is it's probably just
the fact that there is a lot of data to
get through now if you wanted to view it
more if you wanted to view everything at
once then we would have to switch to
some other way of rendering completely
but of course in most situations if
you're not looking at a million quads at
once or in this case what are we
700,000 quads at once then you could of
course just call everything there's no
calling happening at all here no CPU
said calling whatsoever
every quad is being submitted seven
hundred and two thousand cause they're
in that vertex buffer that's what OpenGL
saves us what your GPU says so because
of that of course by just calling
everything to the camera view instantly
you'd be at like pretty much well
probably one or two milliseconds for the
for no matter how many sprites you have
but of course if you want them all in
view which could be useful for like a
particle system or something in the
future then in that case yeah you would
have to come up with a better way to
render that so that's basically what
I've done for today next time I do look
at hazel today which might be next week
I definitely want to add textures and
stuff like that I imagine that will have
a quite a decent impact on performance
as well but we'll see and then that that
will of course affect how we can bash
things together because well we can
certainly have probably up to 32
textures in a single draw but because we
this would have at least 32 texture
slots I imagine but mobile hardware
might not so um that that would kind of
come into the land of we need to know
what platform we're making this for
anyway that is basically what I have
achieved today so I hope you guys
enjoyed this little video I never done
anything like this before as I said so
I'm curious to see what you get what
your guys feedback is if you enjoyed
this if you want to see more of this
kind of stuff in the future it was
definitely very fun to make yeah let me
know what you think in the comments
below and then I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]